charlamos un poco más sobre el plan los
key como me gusta llamarlo ya que es
idea de mi amigo todos los kings y yo
pienso que es un excelente plan pero
veamos cuáles son sus repercusiones y
cuál sería la posibilidad de que
funcione realmente en el vídeo anterior
habíamos comentado que a lo mejor
necesitábamos 50 bancos diferentes pero
eso puede ser bastante difícil así que
en lugar de tener 50 bancos vamos a
imaginar que tenemos solo 5 y en lugar
de que cada uno tenga 14.000 millones
como capital inicial puedes que cada uno
tenga un capital de 140 mil millones
pero aquí el punto es evitar tener un
solo banco que sea muy grande para caer'
por lo que es siempre bueno tener una
sana competencia en estas circunstancias
y debido a que estos bancos tienen una
hoja de balance prístina e impecable
todos estos bancos van a poder hacer
préstamos 10 a 1 y no es nada loco otros
bancos tienen una proporción de 30 o 40
a 1
así que 10 a 1 es normal para un banco y
francamente es muy probable que atraigan
mucha inversión ya habíamos comentado
que a lo mejor otros bancos estarían
dispuestos a invertir en ellos
inversiones privadas también si esto
fueron bancos comerciales lo que
significa que pueden tomar depósitos
muchas personas estarían dispuestas a
poner su dinero en estos bancos ya que
tienen una hoja de balance impecable y
serían propiedad de los ciudadanos de
eeuu de manera individual y además se
tendría este respaldo temporal del
gobierno por cinco años además de los
otros seguros que mencionaré en otros
vídeos y así podremos rastrear los
depósitos que se hacen día con día y las
personas se sentirán mucho más seguras
con estos bancos así que es muy claro
que aquí no tendremos ningún problema en
capitalizar estos bancos pero está la
pregunta de si esto va a resolver el
problema fundamental de mantener los
mercados de crédito fluyendo para
aquellas personas que necesitan de este
crédito ya habíamos mencionado que no
van a tener problemas para acceder a
fondos independientemente de que el
gobierno los pueda capitalizar podrán
atraer depósitos podrán atraer
inversiones de sectores privados y
también de dinero internacional en
especial con este respaldo temporal del
gobierno por cinco años así que podrá
poner esencialmente 10
es más el dinero que tiene como capital
en el sistema tenemos 700 mil millones
de dólares de estos bancos
colectivamente estos podrán meter en el
sistema diez veces más por lo que se
tendrán siete billones de dólares de
préstamos nuevos
y préstamos nuevos
y estos siete billones son prácticamente
la mitad del producto interno bruto de
eeuu y a lo mejor alguno de ustedes
podría argumentar que esto es demasiado
que se proporcionaría demasiado crédito
por lo que esto podría afectar al
sistema así que se puede decir que si no
se quiere tanta liquidez pues se va a
reducir un poco este número en lugar de
tener 700 mil millones
tendríamos 100 mil millones ya que si
tenemos 10 bancos con 100 mil millones
cada uno todos ellos podrán proporcionar
ya que son nuevas obligaciones y nuevos
bienes en hojas de balance impecables se
inyectará un billón de dólares al
sistema como préstamos nuevos que se
pueden usar para que las personas los
inviertan construyendo fábricas y
construyendo cosas reales y ya que su
incentivo no es rescatar a sus amigos ni
ayudar a las compañías para las que
solían trabajar o que les donaron o
contribuyeron hasta cierto punto con
estas personas
este billón de dólares no se destinará
para comprar bienes a un precio mucho
mayor del valor
tienen realmente aunque podría comprar
bienes pero con un precio de descuento
siempre y cuando los administradores de
estos bancos vean que pueden obtener una
buena ganancia aunque la mayoría de
ellos invertirán en áreas de la
industria donde se ve que hay promesa de
buenos réditos y una persona me
comentaba que si esto ocurriera si se
tuvieran ya sean este billón o siete
billones de dinero inyectado en el
sistema si esto no ocasionaría una
inflación y de hecho voy a hacer toda
una serie de vídeos sobre la inflación
ya que creo que no hay mucho
entendimiento al respecto en general si
cualquier persona hace una inversión
positiva por ejemplo si yo tuviera un
dólar e hiciera una inversión en donde
se generará un beneficio de un dólar con
20 centavos esto por definición no es
inflacionario ya que tengo un dólar en
el mundo y he creado una riqueza de 1.20
así que el pastel se hace más grande una
buena forma de comprender la inflación
aunque voy a hablar con más detalle al
respecto más adelante ya que es un
concepto bastante abstracto es imaginar
que este
el pastel de los bienes y servicios que
existen en un año en un país así que
estos son los bienes y servicios que se
producen durante un año en un país y de
este otro lado tenemos el pastel que
corresponde al dinero a la oferta de
dinero que existe y aquí el dinero no se
refiere a los billetes y monedas que
existen físicamente eso está en función
de qué tan rápidamente este dinero se
está moviendo o está involucrado en
transacciones en todo el sistema incluso
ustedes podrían tener toda una economía
en donde existe solamente un billete de
un dólar pero cada vez que alguien
necesita algo de otra persona e
intercambian ese billete de dólar este
billete puede usarse miles de millones
de veces durante un año o incluso
billones de veces por lo que se puede
decir que se tiene no sé 5 billones de
dólares porque esas fueron las
transacciones que se realizaron con ese
billete de dólar pero digamos que este
es todo el dinero que hay en circulación
la cantidad de dinero crece de manera
más rápida de lo que crece el pastel de
bienes y servicios o lo que es la
capacidad productora de ese país
entonces se tiene inflación siempre que
este círculo crezca más rápido que este
otro habrá inflación si este círculo
crece más rápido que este otro tendremos
la deflación
tendremos cierta cantidad de dinero que
representan más bienes y servicios por
lo que los bienes y servicios reales se
volverán más baratos y de eso se trata
este problema de la crisis crediticia es
el problema en donde no se está
multiplicando el dinero ya que si el
gobierno inyecta un dólar en este
sistema bancario roto en lugar de que
este dólar se use como en un sistema
normal en donde cuando uno presta un
dólar
a un banco podemos imaginar que esto es
la reserva federal quien prestó el dólar
a un banco bueno pues este banco se
tiene que quedar con el 10% de este
dinero que recibió y puede prestar el 90
por ciento restante a eso se refiere el
diez a uno tiene que mantener como
reserva diez centavos de ese dólar y le
puede prestar 90 centavos a alguien más
y después este otro banco mantiene en
reserva un 10% que recibió nueve
centavos y presta los restantes 81
centavos y estos 81 centavos se los
presta a alguien más y este banco puede
prestar lo que sea el resultado de este
punto 81 por punto 9 y esta es la idea
en un sistema bancario que funciona
normalmente un dólar que se inyecta el
sistema tiene este efecto multiplicador
de crear más dinero pero lo que está
sucediendo en este momento es que la
reserva federal le presta un dólar a un
banco al banco pero el banco a tiene
tanto miedo que no va a prestar dinero a
nadie más va a conservar ese dólar ya
que su prioridad ahora
no es obtener un interés e incremental
del dinero que puedan prestar su
prioridad principal es la supervivencia
así que ese dólar se fue a un agujero
negro y esto se refiere la frustración
de la reserva federal sigue prestando
dinero al sistema pero ese dinero sigue
desapareciendo y de hecho conforme la
economía se va deteniendo la velocidad
en la que se hacen transacciones de
dinero también va a detenerse así que el
problema principal cuando se tiene una
crisis crediticia y se tiene una
recesión es que la oferta de dinero se
reduce y bueno la oferta de bienes y
servicios también es probable que se
reduzca pero la oferta de dinero se va a
reducir mucho más rápidamente así que
aquí el principal problema es la
deflación este fue el principal problema
de la gran depresión y también fue el
problema principal en la crisis japonesa
y se han escrito artículos al respecto
que afirman que siempre se puede curar
la deflación imprimiendo dinero y
dejándolo caer desde un helicóptero y
hasta cierto punto esto es lo que han
venido haciendo la reserva federal ha
estado dispuesta a tomar riesgos
crediticios muy grandes
invirtiendo dinero en el sistema pero el
problema es que este efecto
multiplicativo está desapareciendo a una
tasa más rápida de lo que es posible
inyectarle dinero por lo que aún se
sigue teniendo deflación y entonces que
se tuviera esta proporción de prestar
diez a uno se tenía prestar 30 a 1 o 40
a 1 por lo que cada dólar que se ponía
en el sistema se convertían en 40
dólares que se le daban a alguien más
que a su vez lo podría proporcionar a
otra persona por lo que se tenía una
enorme explosión de dinero y francamente
la única razón por la que no se tuvo una
inflación es que durante los últimos 5 o
10 años se tuvo una enorme capacidad de
producción en china y en india por lo
que los bienes manufacturados llegaban
mucho más baratos pero para las cosas
que no fueron manufacturadas tuvimos una
enorme inflación de bienes por ejemplo
las cuotas estudiantiles o el seguro
médico cosas que dependían del trabajo
de los ciudadanos de eeuu todas éstas se
volvieron tremendamente caras ya que se
tenía esta enorme inyección
de liquidez aunque se tienen diferentes
maneras de medir el dinero el indicador
principal se llama m3 y aquí bueno
entiendo que me estoy saliendo un poco
del tema y que más adelante haré vídeos
para cubrir en detalle esto el principal
indicador m3 el reporte oficial del
gobierno explotó ya que esta cadena
multiplicativo había explotado sin
embargo ahora se está en una situación
completamente opuesta este efecto
multiplicativo está desapareciendo del
sistema ya no se están haciendo
préstamos mutuos todos están prestando
con proporciones de 30 a 140 a 1 por lo
que el dinero está desapareciendo del
sistema su velocidad está disminuyendo y
aunque esto se está empequeñeciendo este
otro se hace más pequeño más rápidamente
sin importar lo que esté haciendo la
reserva federal por lo que este rescate
de los 700 mil millones de dólares que
están siendo arrojados desde este
helicóptero lo que yo opino es que si se
va a lanzar dinero de un helicóptero la
cuestión es a dónde va a caer ese dinero
el gobierno
que debe de dejarlo caer en el sistema
bancario que ya está roto pero el punto
de este vídeo y de la anterior es
apuntar que es mejor que este dinero
caiga a un nuevo e impecable sistema
bancario o quizás dejarlo caer en el
bolsillo de todos los ciudadanos y ver
qué sucede si pueden formarse en nuevos
bancos y qué harían al respecto de
cualquier manera esto es todo por el
vídeo de hoy sé que estuve hablando de
diferentes temas al mismo tiempo pero yo
espero que hayan comprendido el punto
principal nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo